Звісно, страшно. Особливо вночі, коли починалися обстріли.
У мене був хрестик дерев'яний, він зараз вдома теж десь є,
я брала його в руки і по 150-200 разів повторювала молитву "Отче наш",
хоч я і не особливо віруюча людина, але молитву читала під час обстрілів.
Мене звати Вікторія, мені 29 років, я трансгендерна дівчина,
тобто народилася я хлопчиком. Прослужила 6 років у Збройних силах України,
з них близько 7-8 місяців я пробула в зоні АТО.
Воювала, отримала важке поранення.
Зараз я проходжу гормональну терапію
для зміни себе,
для корекції своєї статі, корекції своєї зовнішності.
Моє тіло не відповідає тому, що я відчуваю зсередини.
Перше усвідомлення своєї інакшості прийшло років в 6-7.
Тоді я взагалі не знала, що зі мною, чому так?
І це були перші сльози, перші розчарування.
Мені завжди подобалися заняття, якими займаються дівчатка, мої однокласниці.
Я в дитинстві дуже часто гралася з дівчатками в дочки-матері, скакалки, класики.
Примірявся мамин одяг. Це коли не було нікого вдома, коли брати в школі, а батьки на роботі.
Мені доводилось копіювати поведінку братів, копіювати поведінку друзів-хлопчиків,
щоб не видавати себе, тому що вже тоді з’явились перші страхи, що зі мною щось не так.
Такий період в житті будь-якої транслюдини називається денайл,
тобто людина відмовляється від свого внутрішнього і живе  відповідно до стереотипів,
які прописані в маркері, який був поставлений при народженні.
Народилась я на Хмельниччині. Звичайна робітнича сім'я.
Два старших брати, обидва служать на даний час.
І це ще один фактор, чому я не хочу називати своє паспортне ім'я,
тому що зараз хтось із знайомих, друзів це побачить
і почнуться запитання, почнеться травля братів.
Через відкидання абсолютне своїх моментів трансгендерності
була поставлена ставка на електрозварювання,
на рихтування автомобілів. Це було звичайне училище - вище професійне.
Ну, і після училища прийшла повістка на службу в армії.
На той момент один із братів вже служив неподалік від дому
і він почав говорити: давай, підписуй контракт.
Я влаштувалась на перший контракт, це були на той час внутрішні війська МВС України.
Дуже багато хто з колег питав:
"А чому в тебе немає пари? А як взагалі, що там в тебе?"
Всіх людей чомусь цікавили мої відносини. І чи є в мене хтось, чи нема.
Отакі моменти...
Відповідно на фоні цих моментів проскакували інколи і гомофобні жарти.
Цей досвід був для мене дуже травматичний.
Після контракту в мене була одна робота - прямі продажі.
Влаштувалась на автомийку. У 2016 році це вже був другий контракт - вже в ЗСУ.
Буквально через два місяці прийшла телеграма з Генштабу, що необхідно
з тилової частини перевести до бойових частин трьох військовослужбовців.
Один військовослужбовець зголосився сам, другого військовослужбовця - добровільно-примусово.
І в самому кінці визвалась я.
В АТО сиділа просто як стрілок на ПКМ -
це кулемет Калашникова модернізований, калібр 7,62.
На той момент, на кінець 2016 року, відстані були взагалі мінімальні -
близько 50 метрів, тобто ми навіть гранати кидали одне одному під окопи.
Я отримую поранення, разом зі мною накриває ще гранатометника нашого.
По нас приліт збоку.
Командир позиції відразу ж бере гранатометника і каже:
"Давай дамо вогонь у відповідь". Ну і мене смикає і каже:
"Бери "карандаші" - це заряди до РПГ осколкові -
і теж йди на вулицю за нами.
Він робить залп, спалах і відразу ховається всередину, в позицію.
Буквально проходить декілька хвилин і я розумію одне:
що щось сталося і я із зарядами до РПГ на руках
просто сповзаю по стіні і не можу рухатись.
У мене абсолютно все тіло ватне.
Я бачу, як гранатометник, який був поруч зі мною, кричить,
намагається мене відкачати, затягнути в позицію.
Це був обстріл з РПГ-7, СПГ-9,
за висновком - це дотичне осколкове поранення
потиличної ділянки голови, відкрита черепно-мозкова травма,
струс головного мозку, акубаротравма.
На службі камінг-аут у мене був вимушений.
Були проблеми, які чітко пов'язані з ендокринною системою.
Я звертаюсь до нашого батальйонного фельдшера,
і говорю, що мені треба до ендокринолога.
Ендокринолог мені каже: "Я - спеціалістка вузької спеціальності, іди до терапевтки".
Я - до терапевта, терапевт дає мені направлення на психіатра і на здачу аналізів.
Професор, гуру психологічних наук чи психіатричних,
як буде правильно, не знаю,
ставить мені діагноз: розлад адаптації,
астено-невротичний синдром, тобто купа діагнозів.
Плюс направляє мене на стаціонарне лікування в психо-наркоклініку.
Я туди приходжу і розумію, що якщо я не зроблю камінг-аут,
мене почнуть лікувати від Бог зна яких захворювань і можуть написати навіть шизофренію.
У моєму військовому квитку стоїть стаття 18Б -
це повна непридатність у мирний час і обмежена придатність у військовий.
І таку статтю насправді ставлять абсолютно всім транслюдям у нас в Україні.
А перед цим був камінг-аут батькам.
Відреагували вони, в принципі, нормально.
Мовляв, не важливо взагалі, що з тобою,
головне, що ти наша дитина, ми тебе приймемо такою, як ти є.
Але зараз їм щось доказати...
У  мене була спроба поспілкуватись з мамою,
щоб вона називала мене Вікторія, щоб не було місгендерінгу.
Ні. Вони звертаються до мене по старому паспортному імені,
звертаються як до сина.
Один із братів теж знає. Я теж зробила йому камінг-аут.
Він якось нейтрально до цього всього поставився - твоє діло, що хочеш, те і роби.
Із друзями, побратимами з армії я не спілкуюся.
Я не робила свій камінг-аут.
Все-таки у мене ще є ця внутрішня боротьба всередині.
Якщо ще командир взводу був більш толерантним -
як він відкликався про всякі ЛГБТ-спільноти,
то загалом мій підрозділ був доволі гомофобний.
Я планую робити юридичний перехід.
Дуже важко довести психіатру, що ти дійсно є трансгендерною дівчиною.
Тобто щоб дійсно довести, це треба прийти до нього на обстеження
ледь не в повному "бойовому розфарбуванні", в сукні, з макіяжем.
Я зараз перебуваю на гормонотерапії п'ятий місяць.
Чому я почала гормональну терапію самостійно,
уникаючи усіх цих бюрократичних і медичних кіл?
Тому що я не бачу іншого шляху. Все це робиться на свій страх і ризик.
Коли я прийду до психіатра, я скажу: ось,
я знаходжусь на такому-то місяці гормональної терапії,
ось, будь ласка, вам мої аналізи, я вже почала і мені не важливо, скажете ви мені "так" чи "ні":
я все одно піду до кінця.
Це фактор впливу на психіатра, щоб отримати бажану довідку.
Поступово я починаю бачити в дзеркалі те, що мені хотілось бачити.
Єдиний біль, який з'явився, - це біль, коли почали рости молочні залози.
Коли вони почали рости, з'явився такий специфічний біль - тільки при дотиках.
Я б із задоволенням зробила хірургічну корекцію, але річ у тому, що
це достатньо дорога операція. У нас в Україні
це коштує  близько 15 тисяч американських рублів.
Дуже мало країн дійсно допомагають транслюдям.
Наша країна доволі гомофобна.
Так, вона потрошки змінюється в ліпший бік,
з'являється молоде покоління, більш толерантне, але агресія залишається.
В цьому році було два чи три напади на трансгендерних людей.
Плюс це захист моїх близьких - це відповідальність перед батьками,
тому що я боюсь миті, коли друзі або колеги батьків запитають:
"А що це таке, кого ви виховали?"
І через це я не хочу на цей момент називати своє паспортне ім'я.
Це дійсно образливо: ну чому я захищала Україну, а тепер я боюсь заявити про себе,
тому що я боюсь, що мене ніхто не захистить?
Тому що, якщо я заявлю про себе,
якщо я вдягнусь так, як мені хочеться і якщо мене поб'ють - я прийду в поліцію,
мені поліція на даний момент скаже:
це твоя вина, не треба було вдягатися так, не треба було так фарбуватись.
Якщо скажуть, що необхідно іти воювати, треба брати до рук зброю -  я піду.
Дійсно є дуже багато людей, які воюють,
які є частиною ЛГБТ-спільноти,
частиною трансспільноти, які служать, які воюють.
Моя найбільша мрія - це
зробити перехід, знайти партнера,
свій будинок, сім'я,
жити звичайною сім'єю, бути щасливою.
Мати свою дитину, свою кровинку.
Але медицина до цього поки не дійшла.
Так, є операції експериментальні, які, можливо,
у майбутньому дозволять трансжінкам виносити дитину
і самостійно народити - нехай це буде через кесареве.
У майбутньому, можливо. Але наразі такого немає.